the second question it says this sure
that I think it's okay so this is poppy
now I didn't know what you think when
you look at that question um it looks
like it's like why is this even a
separate question like if this is one
line right and this is the last line of
my previous thing and I have to show
that what would you think is the most
distinctive thing to do I should like I
could just do tan inverse of both sides
couldn't I right hey buddy tan inverse
of this I should get this right I
determine this at the other side I get
this and that's that's it it's like
where's the what much shorter who it's
if I just wrote it down is that is that
it now here's the reason why this is a
short question
we simply cannot write this there is a
problem we've missed something
okay there is more than just one line
between these two the question is why
why might there be a problem just trying
to go from here to here I've alluded to
it already by something that I've
written on the board can anyone work out
where might there be some issues
I introduced this idea here right
because I said we already know and you
must read more than any other topic
right you've got to be careful for your
restrictions your restrictions change
everything in in verse three and it
usually do that in most topics I'll bet
in verse three
they do right now there's a domain
problem in here there is a domain
problem in here right going from this
line to this line we've all assumed we
all assumed that if I take 10 inverse of
both sides it's okay hmm can I do that
can I just take 10 inverse of both sides
and it works
particularly you have a look at this son
left-hand side over here okay he is 10
inverse of tan PI on 2 - is it always
equal to PI and 2 minus theta and the
answer is sometimes a question is what's
the sometimes what's the sometimes and
for what values is this actually true
okay now if you remember when we graphed
this is your best one on the outside of
a regular one of the inside when you
graph this guy okay this is equal to X
but only sometimes right what does it
look like where does the graph that
looks like I think it'd look like this
didn't something like that okay that
jagged sort of sine curve with straight
lines which is weird okay so you can see
in this spot here that's y equals x
isn't it it passed us to the origin with
the right radio but the rest of it none
of that is y equals x it's only in this
little section here so the question is
what would this thing look like what
would tan inverse of tan look like
now you can try this out okay let's um
did you calculate is that for a second
we're mega deuce
okay now with the calculators let's see
if we can not necessarily draw it
because that will take a while but do
enough investigation that we can work
out where this is going to be useful to
us right let's try though
give me about anything one
what's 10 inverse of 10 1 make sure
you're in the right mode is it 1 okay
that's good
all right give me another value what's
10 inverse of 10 - okay give me another
value 3pi on 2 3 4 ok
is he gonna keep going are you are you
in radians or even degrees ah come on
guys let's try this again actually I
know that well I know that that'll be ok
give me some radios that's it death tell
you to be in degrees well ok radians
alright can we be in radians please yes
still working yeah ok so now what is
give me values yeah what does okay so if
I put in this one we get 11.1 son
rubbish
we don't get this okay that's something
else
pie okay mm okay so so we've we've just
broken through this taking most of ten
something right doesn't necessarily give
you back something okay
I'll save you some time I'll draw you
what's hanging most of Tenex looks like
okay it roughly looks like this okay
kind of weird in fact do you remember
what we what happened over here
we kind of got a straightened out
version of sign didn't we yes this
almost looks like a straightened out
version of tab that's a bit funny isn't
it where are these um where are these
discontinuities at PI on to is it equal
to the top on the bottom think about it
if it's plan to it doesn't equal either
if it doesn't it's a proper it's not
just a I'm equal to one but not the
bottom it's just itself it's a complete
hole right I can actually drop through
there if I put a value pair - okay so if
I'd established this right there is a
portion where this is true which portion
is it from negative PI into so that's
when it works okay all right so let me
see if I can pull this all together okay
I want to look at where am I gonna look
at this thing
okay I want to take 10 inverse of both
sides okay
so I want to consider the tan inverse
tan Phi on 2 minus theta okay I want it
to be equal to PI on 2 minus theta where
is that the case the answer is where
that angle is between negative PI 2 and
PI onto that okay
something says I mean I called the angle
X here but this angle is called ply on 2
minus theta that's the whole angle okay
so therefore I'm gonna need to include
the restriction if you this one whoops
not inclusive it breaks okay now that is
the place that's the domain where I can
say 10 is 10 that does give me that
straight back okay now that's a really
real way to write a domain isn't it
can we tidy this up a little bit how
would we do it any suggestions I can
take away plan to from everything okay
so that's gonna give me on the left hand
side it's gonna give me negative PI
you'll have negative theta in there and
you'll have 0 aren't you okay what
should I do now I could multiply through
by minus 1 right that's gonna change all
the directions of the inequalities
aren't they right so look like this hi
feed are still zero okay but it's a bit
weird writing them from big to small
that's what these mean all right so it's
around is that okay is that all right
okay good so now I know when this is
true okay but the question didn't say
sure that this is true right
for only certain values it just said
sure no conditions applied or are there
are there some conditions on this is
theta restricted where is it restricted
look it's on the board where is what
what one the board tells you that theta
is restricted which bit specifically can
you tell me okay now what
what restriction does that imply just
that one line on its own theater because
tan inverse of X the restriction it
implies is a range restriction on theta
by cos theta can't just go anywhere it's
actually locked in there right when you
write when you draw 10 inverse where is
it locked between from negative pi onto
not inclusive because they're asymptotes
aren't there two pi on to okay now
that's good that's good but that's not
good enough I need this or at least I
need to be in there right so there's
something else what else
ah X is positive x is positive and this
is true right so therefore let me draw
this guy for you there's so much easy to
see
what does tenon bus look like well you
got your two horizontal asymptotes right
all right now if I drew the whole thing
you'd get this shape and just like you
told me it's between negative PI 2 and
PI onto a half but I don't want the
whole graph because the very first thing
I wrote down was X is greater than 0
right so therefore not inclusive I'm up
here okay so in fact I'm even better
than this I'm actually from naught to PI
on two
okay so what this means is you have to
just really careful the way you think
about restrictions okay from the get-go
as soon as we set up the question they
say forget about every value of theta
except for these ones these are the only
ones I'm interested in okay I mean you
start doing some work and when you get
to a restriction like this you think now
the values that I'm interested in are
they within these values and the answer
is yes they are right coz zero to PI
over two is smaller than zero to pi okay
so that's why I can make this statement
right so let me come back to this line
okay
I can say tan of Phi 2 minus theta
equals 1 on X showed above because
that's what I proved in Part A okay now
I can say I should include this line
don't skip this line where you actually
do tan inverse of both sides whoops
at this point I don't need to bring any
domain restrictions in its when I take
this and get rid of evaluate the tan
inverse tan when I do this I need to be
able to justify why this can magically
turn into this because it's not always
that outside this domain it's equal to
other we don't looking things okay I can
say this equals of this as and then I
bring in a domain restriction as 0 theta
it is true this line does go to this
line in this domain because that's what
I'm interested okay so that's why sure
right there isn't just one line between
here and here I suppose in order to
justify this you know this working that
I've included here and actually getting
the domain where it works is actually
invaluable to include just like I have
okay